today's to guest podcast is all about
physical computing programmable
microcontrollers computer science
education and fashion join me along with
a veteran researcher and a newly hired
postdoc researcher for some perspective
on the magic of making with the power of
code you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using computer
programming has often been perceived as
the exclusive domain of computer
scientists and software engineers but
that's changing thanks to the work of
people like dr. Thomas ball a partner
researcher in the rice group of
Microsoft research and dr. Teddy Sayyad
a postdoctoral researcher in the same
group their goal is to make programming
accessible to non-programmers in places
like the classroom the workshop and even
the runway on today's podcast Tom and
Teddy talk about physical computing
through platforms like make code a
simplified programming environment that
makes it easier for young people and
other computer science neophytes to
start coding with programmable
microcontrollers they also tell us about
project Brookdale where they did a
collaborative fashion show that gave
emerging designers the tools to embed
technology in their garments and produce
wearables you'd actually want to be seen
in that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
I want to just start by saying that I've
been waiting a long time to get you two
in the booth with me Tom ball Teddy say
it welcome to the podcast thank you so
much yeah thanks promise Tom yes you're
a partner researcher in the research in
software engineering or Ryze group
here's Microsoft Research and you've
been here a while
teddy you've just been hired as a
postdoc here at Microsoft Research one
way to go yeah I'm kind of a fresh out
of the gate although you've been at the
computer science thing for quite awhile
and we'll get to that shortly but you're
early on in the game so we've got both
ends of the MSR spectrum represented
here and because of that I think this is
going to be an exciting version of this
question what gets you up in the morning
why do you come to work what's your
motivation as they say in the movies
mm-hmm well for me it's the Microsoft
research environment we get to probe
fundamental questions about computer
science and work with an amazing set of
people over my 20 years here I've been
able to hire people ranging from
empirical software engineering
researchers to people doing automated
theorem provers and compilers
programming languages and Teddy is an
HCI expert human-computer interaction
working in the intersection of computing
and wearables and so I just find it
really exciting to be working in an area
where there's a huge amount of diversity
a great amount of talent and it's just
fun for me every five years or so I like
to sort of switch things up and change
things up so I'm at one of those phase
changes in and Teddy is like the face
change agent glad to me that something
like that you're the face of phase
change Teddy what gets you up in the
morning I mean I had a really good
internship experience I mean I was
pretty driven and entrepreneurial kind
of before I came here and then coming
MSR was a really good research
experience for me I remember one of my
first meetings were sitting with Tom and
a few other researchers asked I think as
well and you kind of like oh like wow
these were all people that I have like
read about and they're so open to
collaborating and it was a very
eye-opening experience for me Wow
and then just the internship was
fantastic and so now when I wake
it's like Who am I gonna work with today
and like what kind of things can I do
that I can't do anywhere else so it
really drives me Tom go back just a
little bit this umbrella of Rhys
research in software engineering I've
had many of her colleagues on the
podcast and it seems to be a kind of
phrase that encompasses a lot of
different threads of research is that is
that by design yeah that's really by
design when it was started really by
Wolfram Schultz a back almost I think
2009 I wrote together a lot of different
groups and you know there's so many
aspects to software engineering and
software quality there's lots of
different ways to look at the beast and
it's very complex so we look at
empirical methods we study how people
program Danae Ford Robinson just joined
our group she studies people on github
where we have people doing formal
automated theorem proving to help us
find defects and software our prove that
software doesn't have certain classes of
defects so in general there's a wide
range of problems software quality
software performance and for the most
part we're looking at improving the life
of the professional software developer
although in the last five years we've
expanded we do work really for bringing
the programming tools and technologies
to end-users who may not be programmers
there was work that made it into
Microsoft Excel called flash fill which
is a form of programming by example or
program synthesis and then the latest
stuff that we've been doing with
education is a simplified programming
environment called make code we're
making it easier for middle schoolers to
start programming with embeddable
computers Teddy I want to ask you about
your PhD because it's an interesting one
it's the first of its kind in Canada
yeah because you came out of the
University of Calgary
tell us about your ph.d program what it
involved and how it landed you here so
my early PhD it was really heavily into
software and you know building the Iron
Man type interfaces because I'm a huge
Marvel Comics fan and I love Iron Man so
I was really interested in like building
all those things and I got really good
at it and then I was interested in the
business side so I was working first
startup in Calgary and I didn't really
understand sometimes sort of the
business lingo of how
you know like a p.m. would communicate
with an external customer I done a lot
of demos and things like that and I was
quite comfortable but it was different
being able to communicate with VPS and
xx yeah so then I was like okay I'll
take some MBA classes so I did that as
part of my like actual degree and then I
really liked it and I also found it
interesting because it was very related
to the research I was doing in terms of
methodology right where you know I might
run a couple studies to get a paper
whereas an entrepreneurial side I'm
running studies to actually like make
the product better so it was like very
much the same for me early on ok and
then I got a bunch of experience doing
you know hardware startups and I got
really interested in hardware and then I
brought that into my own research so I
started doing more hardware projects as
part of my dissertation so I did a
SmartWatch and a smartphone and both of
them did really well they got on Gizmodo
and Forbes magazine and things like that
the watch was instant for me because I
was actually trying to build it so I was
pushing to VCS and trying to raise
capital and sort of struggling with that
but what was interesting in that journey
was I wanted to make something that was
unique that was from my perspective that
wasn't something from Google or Apple
right because they were doing
smartwatches at the time so I jumped
into the world of fashion and I got
stuck there because I'm trying to
communicate with people that are
technical at all and try to teach them
concepts and it was always very
frustrating for me to do that and I just
stayed there because it was a really
good place to sort of learn and
experiment how great wearables I was
having impact on my community with
working with kids and teaching them tech
through fashion so it was just a really
good place to be I mean coming to MSR I
was working on a start-up by the time
that was doing the fashion tech kit and
then I emailed the make code team out of
the blue it was not expecting answer
back from Tom but Tom replied and we had
a I think it was supposed to be half an
hour call end up being a bit longer I
think you came out yeah quick visit yeah
a quick visit and then you know they
were like you want your internship I was
like sure Tom mm-hmm I always find it
interesting from the perspective of two
different people like he's a grad
student in Calgary and he thinks I'm
gonna email the mothership right
Microsoft so how do you receive these
emails you get this from this guy what
do you think well I mean you go check
out what he's been doing right and it's
like wow this is really interesting and
we had been working with the BBC on the
micro bit so we knew about the embedded
technology space and how it was
being used by schools but also had a
little familiarity with its use in the
maker spaces and fashion and so this
just seemed like a really great match we
had helped the product group stand up
the make code product which started in
research and we were looking for what's
the next thing and you know sometimes
well luck favors the prepared right and
so we were prepared and Teddy was
prepared and we were both it was good
timing although we had to wait another
year before we really got things going
because we had some stuff going and
Teddy had some stuff going so you know
the email was the seed but it got a lot
of thought processes going about taking
this idea of democratizing technology
and really making it broader than just
CS education in the schools but many
people need to control and use computers
as part of their work and one of the
ways you control the computer is through
programming and trying to simplify that
so you may not be a computer scientist
or even ever take a computing class or a
programming class but you're going to be
faced with using the technology are
making use of it well let me go upstream
with you there because downstream we've
got some tangible products and tangible
projects but I'd like you to talk a
little bit more upstream about making
computer programming accessible here
we're talking about people who might not
think of themselves as programmers or
even able to begin thinking that way so
how have you attacked this from a 10,000
foot view right well at the very high
level I feel like people want to be in
control of their lives and in control of
computers they don't want to feel like
their lives are controlled by computers
right and I think that the way that you
gain control is through education and
through understanding and to be educated
or to have control you need to be more
educated about how computers work and
then how to make them do your bidding so
I think you know fundamentally that
nations around the world have recognized
that CS education is just as important
as an education and say reading writing
arithmetic physical sciences and
Microsoft from its roots starting with
basic and
giving people the foundational tools to
be able to control the computer that's
part and parcel of what we do and the
great part these days is it's just much
easier because of the internet because
of the web because it's easy to get
access to all these technologies if you
have access to a computer hook to an
Internet which is not a given everywhere
it's not it's not Universal but if you
think about today compared to when I got
started in the late 70s there's so much
more available for people who want to
learn about computing and then become
educated to learn how to control the
computers themselves
[Music]
let's talk more in depth about
Microsoft's ESN platform make code Pelly
de Hulu was on the podcast or a while
ago and talked about make code back then
why don't we review a little bit
tell us what make code is how and why it
came about and where is it getting
traction right now mit code actually
started out of previous project from
Microsoft Research from the rise group
called touchdevelop and the idea there
was very simple everybody has these
smartphones but in order to program the
smartphone you need another computer why
can't you program your smartphone using
the same smartphone and Nikolay Hillman
had this great idea anyhow most skaaland
Pelley joined in and I came in a little
later and so we created an app to make
it possible to write little programs
that controlled your smartphone but
using your smartphone as the programming
environment and from that we got to
essentially a touch based code editor
that you could use a single finger to
program with the BBC a few years later
had this idea of the BBC micro bit and
this is a little embeddable computer
that has its roots in the arduino system
sort of a visible printed circuit board
with some flashing lights in buttons on
it and they wanted a programming
environment that was web-based to help
take the micro bit to all the fifth
graders or year seven and the united
kingdom and so we used touchdevelop to
essentially deliver that system in 2015
2016 and when we were code complete with
touchdevelop for the BBC micro bit we
said okay we're going to create a
compiler from the touchdevelop system
into the make code system we demoed it
internally and externally this pxt with
the editor the new editor for the micro
bit and we got interest from the
Microsoft execs as well so they funded
the make code product group so we have
it now some developers on that side a
program manager and on the research side
telling me how myself Steve Hodges now
Teddy who are thinking more about what
can we do with this platform moving
forward so it started with really
simplifying programming for complex
devices and
first complex device was a smartphone
then we went to the BBC micro bit and
now with make code we've expanded from
the micro bit to a number of other
devices but these devices are generally
battery-powered like your smartphone but
not quite as resource-rich as a
smartphone they're they're much lower
power and smaller well that's an
excellent segue into what I want to talk
to Teddy about next which is using
programmable technology micro
controllers in fashion so tell us about
your personal hack the runway vision and
how you decided to take hi-tech into
fashion and what you call oat tech coach
or the vision before I started I mean
when I hit emailed Tom and the Miko team
was you know I had done a lot of work
with Arduino and a lot of workshops with
kids and designers and just a lot of
time was not used optimally in the
workshops and it was just becoming
really frustrating so that's kind of how
I came across make code and that was
really great and then during the
internship the vision that I had wanted
and sort of my bigger vision is I don't
really think a tech company should be
making wearables I think it should to be
coming from the fashion world we should
be providing tools for them and to be
able to create these things right but in
order for us to get there we need to
create something that designers can use
and like if you think of them as
developers we need to create developer
tools but these developers are fashion
designers then we can solve all this on
the technical side and in the meantime
when things are ready and you know
things are washable and stuff they'll
have that experience to be able to make
the things that we want that's kind of
the vision that I had okay to start
anyways I want to press in a little bit
there because to me you're making
developer tools but you're giving them
to people's aren't developers actually
so how does that work that's I guess a
little bit more on the HCI side so on
the HCI side you spend a lot of time
working with designers working with
people that are not sort of technical of
trying to figure out what their
challenges are how they're thinking
about design
what are thinking about fabrics and
materials so I spent a lot of time sort
of before the internship just thinking
about fashion really and how that world
works in understanding the lingo because
obviously one of the biggest things is
communication where do you have people
that are super technical and people that
are not technical at all in bridging
that worlds very difficult but one of
the ways to do that is through
communications okay so let's say I'm a
complete neophyte do you have to teach
me
computation or thinking with work that
we had done I typically don't start with
technology at all actually it really
starts but what's the story you're
trying to tell
hmm right every garment has a story it
reflects the person wearing it so what
is the story you want to tell
then from the story it becomes okay what
kind of technology can use so for
example if you wanted to do a story
around how you felt that day then you
probably want to use some sort of sensor
that measures your emotion right then we
can talk about how to measure emotions
and then after that we can talk about
where you would place the sensors and
then it becomes the question of where
you placing on the body how you're
sewing it in then it's like how do you
want power this thing right so there's
sort of a narrative but it's all
starting from the story and I'm a
platform side I think we have to have
these components that can meet those
needs and that's where the complication
comes they're the designer might have
something that's really not technically
possible we can meet them halfway or say
these are the sort of things that we
have in mind we might have a set of
animations that are pre-built that they
can choose from in parameter AHS
visually not by programming but by
drag-and-drop menus by demonstration but
there would be you know a more visual
interface to start with especially if
it's a visual you're designing you know
I think you also see that in the classic
visual basic forms editing you know you
get people creating these forms
applications who would drag and drop
widgets onto the screen and there was
the code behind and I think for a lot of
domains that sort of paradigm of having
a visual editor with domain-specific
representations in this case it might be
about the sensors or the garment or the
lighting and the animations backed by
code that the designer wouldn't
necessarily have to edit themselves but
it would be there for somebody else in
the design production pipeline to sort
of go and maybe tweak that's all right
so you have to bring new people into the
design production pipeline probably yeah
that's part of what we're trying to do
in the make code system is T's
JavaScript and typescript to program
these embedded devices so that we have
access to this world of web developers
who know JavaScript for doing webpages
but may never have thought of using it
for programming a fashion garment but
now they could use those same
technologies for doing so
let's talk about project Brookdale now
this is why I wanted you to in the booth
it happened not that long ago but it was
exciting enough for me that I started to
ask when can I get these guys on the
podcast so I could give a big run up for
this but I'd rather have the two of you
tell us about this research project what
is project Brookdale how did Microsoft
research get together with the Brooklyn
Fashion Academy and what were the
results of bringing microcontroller
technology to the Atelier so the nice
thing about this project was I don't
think I could have done it anywhere else
and one of the things I was trying to do
in my grad school was like be able to
properly build something and give it to
fashion designers and deploy it on a
runway and see what would happen right
the nice thing about the runway is that
it's a very practical way of teaching
you about wearables right it's all the
conditions of heat on the body things
breaking people moving things being
packed all the sort of crazy conditions
that you would typically have a test for
individual you can get all in like sort
of this nice runway idea and so when we
came to do project Brookdale it was
really about how do we make a system
easy for people that are not technical
in this case that audience was fashion
designers and you had had a contact I
guess one buddy and I had in this
fashion academy exactly I had contacts
with the Brooklyn Fashion Academy
already and so it just worked perfectly
the timing of being able to build the
hardware in the software and going there
in sort of deploying the system no I
should say on the make code side we had
been working on this new make coat
arcade a game engine and James Devine
who was another intern was started
working with us in the summer of last
year on Jack deck which is a way to
network together microcontrollers so we
talked about programming the
microcontrollers with web technology but
how do you program a web of
microcontrollers well you need to be
able to hook them up and that was just
to hook up to game machines so you could
have multiplayer gaming but then when
Teddy came along and said oh I have this
fashion thing we were like oh well maybe
we can also wire him up on the body and
have this easier way to connect together
different microcontrollers that would
then be part of a garment and so sort of
a plug-and-play microcontroller based
tool kit to make it easy to prototype
and so we in make code we had a bunch of
new technology Teddy brought the
application and
and we all brought it together and it
did come together the hardware the new
software the designs from the designers
and this team in Brooklyn in a last week
mad dash to the runway it was an
experience and ever to be replicated not
to be forgotten but not to be well tell
you tell us a little bit more about how
this instantiated on the runway yeah so
the theme of the show was the Herrera
women of Namibia so the fashion was sort
of influenced by the Victorian era style
they had brought forward into the future
so each designer brought their own sort
of theme and background into how they
were using technology so over two and a
half month period rather than building
every possible sensory we picked sensors
that were based off of their stories one
of them had their really personal story
about fabric and mental health issues so
she had tears kind of coming down her
her dress and that was one that Tom had
worked on hmm some of them used motion
there was one really cool one where it
was sort of a yellow fabric and he had
two lights coming down on the side there
were Herrera women always worked in the
farms and with cows if he had the steam
of some of the woman being strong like
the cows and sort of walking forward so
there was a lot of things like that so
Teddy did a lot of interviewing and
there was education both ways about
learning about the designs they wanted
to create and then about the technology
and the possibilities so there was a
tremendous amount of interaction in the
lead up while we were scoping out you
know the software and the hardware yeah
and I mean like even harder for example
we didn't design it like the brain for
example is round because it was going to
be on the center of the body according
to most of designs that we had worked
with and then things like the beads we
designed to be sort of cylinder to the
body so it's gonna be it placed on any
part of the body and then we color-coded
them because we wanted designers be able
to use them without us being around so
you would know that red would be light
and you know yellow would be environment
and things like that so it was very
heavily driven by a lot of the work at
the very beginning just interviews in
communication all right so this is both
a research project and a runway project
what were your findings I mean I would
imagine you came away learning a lot
after you tried this with these fashion
designers and fashion design students
what have you come away with in term
of where you'd go next with something
like this well I think from the platform
angle we proved out some new technology
so the Jack tech networking the software
the ease of use of the plug-and-play
and sort of learning about failure
conditions whenever you try to do a
rocket launch a lot of the rockets are
gonna end up not to making it into space
and you learn from that similarly with
the garments there were failures and we
learned a lot about power delivery we
learned a lot about the networking and
really this was just the first prototype
to get to the next step which is to try
to make a design that's more robust it's
still a work in progress mo you know
proving at the technology and
understanding the failure modes was I
think a major aspect so I'm just talking
from the platform yeah I mean we didn't
do as much programming with designers as
we'd like we didn't have time and it
turned out actually maybe having a
laptop the code the garment is not a
good idea maybe we should actually use a
mobile phone
mmm was one finding one of the other
ones was you know the audio jack stuff
was really great for prototyping but
what is it going to be like if we do
wireless right I mean anything Bluetooth
or Wireless is kind of the ideal
condition for wearable but the unique
thing about the runway is it's so noisy
there's cellphones going there's all
these radio signals going around so that
might not be the best idea right okay
doing some of the stuff more integrated
into fabric is kind of the next phase -
so all right so all of this is available
open source am i right
so my code is all open source the
software platform the hardware that we
prototyped for brookdale is not
available yet but there are devices like
the micro bid and the Adafruit circuit
playground Express that you can do
similar things with that are available
from our hardware partners so there is a
lot available already but not the actual
brookdale bead and brain yet it will be
coming so yeah that's the plan
I'll be coming soon to a runway near you
or someplace else yes well let's talk
about open source for news that came
because it's a huge trend over the past
I'm gonna guess a decade but maybe more
hmm what are the factors that have
influenced this shift in your mind Tom
and why is it important to the broader
software ecosystem especially when it
comes to research yeah it's really
transformative for the industry I mean
every company has to think about
what it's secret sauces and it's special
value that it adds and so much can be
found on open source that can be used
that you can then add your value on top
of that so for example make code uses
two editors that we didn't have to
create one is the text editor code named
Monica which is part of the S code we
just extract that component use it the
visual programming with the colorful
blocks is from Google it's the Google
block Lee these are both open source
we've actually made contributions back
to for example the Google Berkeley
codebase we have regular calls with them
that was unimaginable 20 years ago when
I joined Microsoft as well in research
it's great when a PhD intern or any
intern is coming to Microsoft they can
see the project we're working on before
they even arrive they can have a much
more productive three months and then
after they leave they still have access
so contrast that to 20 years ago
we're often you know people came in they
worked on something great and left their
mark but then once they went back to the
University it was much harder to have
access and so I think just overall
people realize it's a win-win when
there's still opportunities obviously
for every company to choose what they
retain sort of behind their firewall
which is their secret sauce and I think
every company does that to some extent
but I think there's been a realization
for collaboration for productivity than
for so many domains it's much easier if
you can see the code and be open from
day one
it's time for what could possibly go
wrong on the Microsoft Research podcast
oh goody oh yeah at this point in the
show I like to have a little
conversation about the possible risks
associated with innovative technologies
that we showcase here so are there any
concerns floating around in your worlds
anything that keeps you up at night well
yeah I'll go back to sort of the control
aspect I think that there's a real
danger that we are losing control of the
computing technology and when I look at
what's happening around the world social
media and the use of AI and all these
computers on the edge that are going to
collect all this great data you know
there are great benefits to come from
that but as we've seen risks and you
know that sort of stuff that really you
know 25 years ago when I was getting
into Industrial Research wow I didn't
really project that we would be where we
are today with sort of wrestling with
these issues around really are we in
control of the computers are the
computers in control of us so what are
you thinking then and I guess the better
question was your people doing about it
this is this is why I think make code
and things like education CS education
are important part of what we're doing
is making it easy to make this invisible
fabric that runs our live visible like
to talk about what is a computer what is
networking security and privacy people
need to become more educated and
starting at an earlier age to understand
with age-appropriate content you know
what is it that this smartphone is doing
for me what are the dangers in being out
on social media and how do I take charge
of my data how to take charge of my
programs and I think we're still sort of
in the infancy of thinking about that at
a scale and so I think the education is
really critically important and that's
what we're helping to do through I think
things like make code and giving people
the tools and the vocabulary to talk
about computers and computing so they
can be just informed citizens really and
they can help in
policymakers so I really do think you
know we need to start earlier so that
the people become educated right did you
address any of this when you were
completing your PhD I started working on
it sort of towards the end I guess I had
read this is a really cool little
workshop and nova scotia with kathy snow
from Cape Breton University I think
she's moved now all right what we did
was we just got girls in their parents
so the elders as well in that community
to basically make traditional indigenous
garments with technology in them and you
know I took a step back in that workshop
interesting because I'm usually the one
leading it and so I let a couple of my
friends angel Alex sort of run that
workshop and like it was just amazing to
see the difference that it made for
those girls these are huge questions I'm
glad to get thinking about them it's
story time as we mentioned at the outset
you're both working here at Microsoft
Research but at different points along
the career path so tell us how you
landed here just give us a kind of short
story of your journey to MSR what
brought you here and why I've been an
industrial research for 26 years now 20
years at Microsoft Research and six
years before that at Bell Labs Bell Labs
was amazing but I was thinking well
programming languages and programming
tools where's the future for that and
Microsoft was clearly the answer for me
and so 20 years later I have to say it
was a pretty good bet and it's still I
think the great place to work on
programming tools programming languages
software engineering but really I had
decided I was a programming language
researcher and around 99 I decided it
was time to sort of go someplace where
that would be really valued for the long
term how about you teddy
I mean I've mentioned before I was
always kind of entrepreneurial
throughout the PhD and then I came to
MSR as the intern and I basically
continued sort of in my entrepreneurial
spirit and that's basically what sort of
rocked the boat for me kind of working
here and then obviously working with Tom
Paley Miho dusty I mean everyone was
just fantastic to work with so I really
couldn't say no right well let's go a
little further on the personal aspects
Tom I happen to know something
interesting about you that I just
learned like all right
forty minutes ago but is there anything
that people might not know about you and
might not assume about you that has
influenced your life or your career
people know I have a really loud voice
and I'm trying to sticking my foot in my
mouth but you know goes back to junior
high where you could get out of one gym
class a week if you did something in
fine arts or singing and I was like oh
my gosh there's nothing I hate more than
the gym locker room so let me give it a
chance in choir so I've always had music
in my background and my parents were
amateur musicians and so sort of a
musician in computer scientists clothing
I like to compose I've sung in the
Seattle Opera chorus I play some piano
badly I play electric bass and a rock
band
I even composed the song about the micro
bit which is a production which is yeah
and then we went to a conference in the
UK and I worked with a band there to
premiere it at the micro bit education
foundations first conference so yeah the
music has always been something for me
that is a creative outlet but also an
inspiration for new thoughts and I'm
thinking of more ways to weave that into
my research soon
yes sooner than later Teddy what don't
we know about you I think I've mentioned
I'm a huge comic book fan right I mean
that's like my whole jam is comic books
that's what's driven me on on a lot of
things that I make especially Iron Men
at the beginning huge Wolverine fan
because he's Canadian and he's short
like I am right so and he's from Alberta
which is also where what yeah Wolverine
is my favorite comic book he's from
Canada yeah he's from Kennedy's from
Alberta in fact that's specific well
yeah if there's a scene in one of the
x-men movies where he's actually in
Alberta so I actually got into computer
science through this computer animated
show called a reboot which was from this
company called mainframe in Vancouver
and it was like teaching you basic
computer science concepts without ever
knowing it and then when I first got
into University I was learning all this
like computer science copter oh this is
actually all the characters I loved in
like reboot are actually concepts so I
made for the easy for me and that
wouldn't yeah so I really love reboot
mmm
I'm learning so much I did not either
that's the point of it right at the end
of every show I ask my guests to share
some parting thoughts with our listeners
and this could come in the form of
advice or inspiration I think this whole
podcast has kind of been that for me or
you could predict the future definitely
don't want to put yeah you know I just
wanted to say because I didn't get a
chance you know
why make code we came up with that name
and I think it really ends up talking to
the idea that what is it you want to
make what is it you want to create and
the idea of putting creativity first and
then bringing the computing and the
coding into that context a lot of times
when we lead with coding I think there's
a certain set of people who get turned
off but if we lead with making whether
that's making an art project or music or
a fashion garment or you want to measure
something about the environment to
realize a better irrigation system you
have a system you have a problem in mind
and the computing and the coating are
part of that so I think it's really good
to think about domains and problems
first and then bring the coding in and
support as just one tool I'll follow up
with what Tom said thinking about domain
I think for future researchers who kind
of want to do what I did in terms of
entrepreneurship I think the biggest
lesson learned for me was at the
beginning I was probably more focused
and the entrepreneurial side and
business I would say as we're sort of
the last couple years is more focused on
impact right we're like how can I go
into community how can I make change you
know one way is going through MIT code
and using that in workshops and you nova
scotia or you know working with
designers it's really about impact for
me the entre no sighs so emphasizing the
impact of the things are working and
thank you sort of for the bigger picture
is really important
Tom ball teddy sad thanks great awesome
[Music]
to learn more about how software
engineering researchers are working to
simplify the programming experience
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]